Good evening, everyone.
It is my pleasure to invite you all to the postdoc discussion and conversation session
in which we heard from Professor Nisheeth Vishnoi on Friday.
As you all may remember,
Professor Vishnoi who is the Bartlett Giamatti Professor of
Computer Science and Co-Founder of
the Computation and Society Initiative at Yale University,
does foundational research on computation and as we saw
from the examples he gave us in his talk, his expertise spans multiple disciplines
and a range of problems that deal with the issue of bias in algorithms.
Today, it is a real treat for us to be able to witness
a conversation between two stalwarts in
the field, and our conversant is Professor Aleksander Madry,
who is the Cadence Design Systems Professor of
Computing at the MIT Electrical Engineering and Computer Science Department,
as well as he's a member of
the Computer Science and Artificial Intelligence Lab, CSAIL at MIT.
He received his Ph.D. from MIT in 2011.
Prior to getting, couldn't stray far from MIT.
Prior to that, he spent a year as
a postdoctoral researcher at Microsoft Research New England,
which incidentally is like a stone's throw away from MIT.
But he did earn his chops by going further afar.
He was on the faculty at EPFL until early 2015.
He currently serves as the director of
the MIT Center for Deployable Machine Learning and is the faculty lead of the CSAIL-MSR
Trustworthy and Robust AI Collaboration.
His research spans machine learning,
optimization and algorithmic graph theory.
He has a strong interest in building on the existing machine learning techniques to forge
a decision-making tool kit that is reliable and well understood
enough to be safely and responsibly deployed in the real world.
You can see how these two interlocutors are
going to engage and teach us a lot about some of
the challenges that Professor Vishnoi brought to the fore for bias in
algorithms and since we are going to encounter them in our daily lives,
whether we like it or not, that for the future,
issues of understanding bias,
how algorithms reveal our biases and how, in turn,
not only do they expose us,
but how we can actually learn and mitigate our own biases,
are the questions that we are hoping to learn from both of you.
Aleksander, I invite you to take it away and get started with the discussion. Welcome.
Welcome, everyone.
Thank you for the invitation.
It's really a treat to be here and treat for many reasons.
In particular, Nisheeth is someone that is a close friend,
and there is a lot of parallel between mine and his trajectory.
In particular, he also was a faculty at EPFL.
We almost overlapped.
I guess we technically overlapped, and that's kind of intensive institutions.
But I think more importantly, intellectually,
there is a lot of parallel between how
our research trajectories evolved and what questions we were drawn to.
In particular, both Nisheeth and I,
our roots are in theory of computer science, in optimization algorithms.
But again, it was interesting to see that even though we did not interact that much,
our interests in some ways aligned on similar topics, so that says something.
To be honest, after watching Nisheeth's talk,
I almost tempted not to have any slides.
I thought that he did a really great job of providing
a backdrop for a discussion and highlighting very important topics.
But then since his talk,
he called me out a couple of times that I am
supposed to say something, I will, and hopefully,
this will provide a little bit of
a different angle at the questions that I will also articulate towards the end,
and so I hope that after this highlighting,
we can have a very important conversation.
One more thing I want to say is that,
beyond just me engaging with Nisheeth,
I want to view it as a little bit even on
a broader sphere in a sense that I really think that these questions,
and that's what Nisheeth beautifully embodies is
that they really go beyond computing or computer science.
I think these are the questions that touch on all of science and all of
our understanding of society and different facets of society.
A place like Yale is definitely a great conversation partner for this discussion.
I guess Nisheeth can channel much of
this wisdom there, but I'm looking forward to engaging.
Again, let me get started.
Essentially, as I said, similarly to Nisheeth, until maybe 2016,
I was happily doing just theory and that was the only thing I
cared about, but then some interesting things happened.
We all know that machine learning,
after some advancement, particularly in computer vision, became the thing.
It became the thing that got everyone's attention
and started to be actually deployed and put
into just about anything, and I must say that as these things unfolded,
I was somewhat unfazed,
like not the first hype happening,
not the last one either.
It was nice to see,
it was important to explore,
but I was not personally moved.
Things changed me, though.
When I started to ask myself the question,
there was some talk that I was attending,
just out of curiosity, and the question that I would say, are we there yet?
In some ways, yes,
we have these advances,
the things that seem to be science fiction just like
10 years ago, now seem to be easy to do,
like you touch this, you touch translation, it works.
You touch this, it works,
so are we done?
Did we find this silver bullet?
Essentially, all that will happen now for the next decade or so,
we will just figure out how to polish things,
how to scale up things but essentially we are already there.
That got me thinking about, okay,
so there are clearly some cool demos happening there, but what does actually would it
take to think about machine learning deployed in a responsible way?
Of course, to even have a premise
of a reason to deploy machine learning in the first place,
you need to have performance.
There has to be some value that the systems can deliver, and I guess this was done.
This was provided.
There is some value in using
the systems but then you especially being a theorist and thinking of
optimization and different aspects of much of theories about understanding
the phenomena at play deeply and
understanding all the ways in which none of these ways in which something can fail.
You start thinking about robustness,
start thinking about the question of performance on data that is unvetted or untrusted.
You think about reliability,
about trying to know every system fails.
But what is important is that whenever it fails,
whenever it moves away from the conditions that it was designed to work for,
it should fail in a graceful way.
The question is like that's what I call reliability,
like to what extent these machine learning systems exhibit this behavior?
Then, there is also an additional question of like I call interpretability.
There are many other ways, explainability and similar.
But the point was that there could be some desire and
need for us to be able to inspect the given model to
provide some quality assurance or think about regulating behavior or essentially
trying to provide a bit more of
a nuanced understanding of what the model is doing and why.
When you start asking about these facets,
you realize, you ask again,
do we have that already?
In particular, much of my work was
focused on the questions of robustness and reliability,
the answer becomes quite clear and very obviously, not at all.
In particular, much of my work was focused on this prevalent brittleness of
our current machine learning tools, so one
of the most classical ways of demonstrating this
are something called the [inaudible] little examples.
Here's an example of an [inaudible] additional example.
We have this beautiful picture of a pig
which state-of-the-art classifier recognizes as a pig with 91 percent confidence,
so everything exactly as advertised.
But now, the funny things start to happen
if I start to add a little bit of noise to it.
This is not a random noise.
This is a noise that is created in a specific way, I will not talk about how.
But the point is, this is a very tiny noise,
like the image you get after adding this noise is essentially
indistinguishable to you as a human from the one on the left.
Essentially, nothing should change except for this model.
Suddenly, this model is convinced that what we have
here is an airliner with very high confidence,
and this is the desired thing.
This machine learning is able to make pigs fly,
that's clearly an achievement of strength.
But of course, this is clearly not what we would intend to happen.
Then it goes deeper. Then it's realized this is not just
about me playing with pixels in an image and getting those results.
There was a bunch of MIT undergrads who created a turtle, that actually
is classified as a rifle from most angles and views.
Previously, this was more about
adversarial design in which we tried to engineer for these things to happen.
But actually, if you look around at the deployment
of different machine learning systems like in Tesla's,
you see that there are plenty of examples where
these things just tend to relatively regularly fail.
Here, just what happened is this was on a highway,
there was an overturned truck
and somehow Tesla's autopilot system did not realize that there
is anything in its way and it just tried to drive.
No one got hurt, everything ended up well, but clearly,
this was a glitch we did not expect.
Now, I could spend hours to tell you
a little bit more about different facets of this brittleness.
But that's not fascinated me, and I think it
is not something that would be really that important for the discussion.
I think the question that is important to ask ourselves is,
what is the root of this brittleness?
Why are these machine learning systems so brittle?
Essentially, long story short is that
one realization is that once you start looking deeply into that,
you realize that it's about data in large part.
Like data matters a lot.
In some ways, especially when we think about machine learning,
we tend to focus on the models.
Because this is what draws our attention.
There is the new transformer model,
new ResNet model,
and it has that many parameters, and this seems to be the magic.
But really as much as there is some magic in that,
the huge part of what drives the performance of the systems is data.
The data that we actually make these models ingest
and essentially that end up informing decisions.
In particular, this is almost obvious to anyone who thinks about data is that
essentially if you think about what our machine learning currently does,
all it does really is an excellent correlation extractor.
The way the "prediction" is happening is that during training,
the model figures out different patterns in
data that correlate well with one label versus the other,
and then the way the prediction happens on new input is just
like you look at the patterns present in this image,
and you use this correlation data to make your prediction.
On the one hand, this is a very successful approach.
It does some remarkable things,
but I actually view it also as a huge problem of the current systems.
Again, it might not be obvious yet,
but many of the things that Nisheeth talked about on Friday actually stem from that.
Of course, the problem is the spurious correlations at the high level.
That causation is not correlation.
We all know that by now,
and the problem is that,
there are correlations that are not causal,
but essentially are spurious.
But now, the question is why does it matter so much and why this is such a problem?
The problem I would say is two-fold.
First of all, if you know that all my model is doing extracting correlations,
then, well, I can essentially plan these correlations.
If I'm adversary in particular,
I can plan these correlations into my data.
Here, let's say I have dogs versus cats training set.
If I make the top-left pixel encode whether this is a dog or cat,
what will happen is the model trained on that
will never even bother to learn how a cat or a dog looks like.
It will try to read the color of the pixel, that's all it will do.
This hijacking of the decision process of this model is actually very important.
In particular in the context of security,
there are some very interesting and amusing ways of exploiting that.
This is being the correlated extractors can be
easily exploited in this way wherever you can play with data maliciously.
But I think the more important point particularly for today
is that these correlations already exist in our data right now.
Just one example, even in the data set like ImageNet,
it turns out that some of the cat versus dog images like
you realize that there are bow ties put on both animals.
But it tends to be for some reason cats more often than dogs.
Now, that's a funny fact,
but what happens after that is that
what model learns from such data is
that presence of a bow tie actually is an indication
that this image is more likely to be a cat image versus a dog image,
which clearly is not too sound of a conclusion, even if supported by data.
In fact, this goes even deeper.
It turns out that the way we create datasets
gives rise to these spurious correlations and biases.
My favorite one is just the question that we might ask.
ImageNet is one of the big datasets
that much of research and development of ML is based on.
You can ask yourself what does a notion of a fish mean
according to image intake?
The important background here is that ImageNet is sourced from social media,
from a website called Flickr.
You need to start asking yourself,
if I never knew,
like I didn't have a concept of a fish,
I've never had seen fish.
No one explained to me what a fish is, and I just wanted to
learn it from this data from social media what fish is.
Well, it would be kind of an interesting concept of fish
because most of the pictures of a fish on social media look like that.
Because people shared on social media only because they want to
show the fish they saw or maybe the fish they ate.
There are very few photos of someone actually diving in and
trying to take a photo of a fish in its natural environment.
But now that's natural to us when you think about it but now think
what happens if we give this data to correlation extractor?
Well, what can happen is that the model will learn that essentially having a human hold
something like that in the picture makes it into a fish image.
Similarly, it learns that the natural environment for a crab is a plate,
because that's where it sees most of the crabs.
These are some ways in which this system has learned
biases that we would not think as valid, but well, they are supported by date.
Of course, here we are talking about
just recognizing cats versus dogs or fish, we might say, who cares.
But then, these things do matter when we deploy in the real world,
and in particular the use of machine learning in
the context of medical context is right for examples in
which we have predictive patterns in
the quotes that actually are not what we would like the model to learn.
This is roughly just a quick run-through of some of the issues that in particular,
I think about a lot,
and again in a moment, I will connect it to
the issue of that Nisheeth thinks about as well.
Because I think the way I like to understand what's really
going on here is that there is this what I call Human-ML misalignment,
this emergent realization that success at a task,
the way we phrase it in
a mathematically precise way does
not mean that the model is doing what you intended it to do,
that it learns the desired concepts that we want.
Just in the context of vision, if I want to
train my model to recognize dogs by just saying,
you need to recognize dogs, [inaudible] you need to get the label right,
well, we have this expectation that the only way to do it
is the way the human does,
to learn that there is a different structure of the fur,
you need to realize what the snout is and so on.
That's the only way to perform this task very well.
But the reality is that it's not true, that ML systems learn very different ways of
solving the tests that completely do not
involve learning any of the concepts we assume they are learning.
There is this misalignment with this technology,
it's really using patterns that we as humans
not only would not use,
but you might not even be able to comprehend.
Where does it take us now?
Well, it takes us to first realization that if you
think about essentially all the questions,
all the problems that we are grappling with,
in the context of ML including the questions of bias,
they really boil down to this human-ML misalignment, saying we have certain set of
beliefs and then we have
some mathematically precise definitions, and we're trying to equal.
The worst things happen if you assume they are the same.
In particular, a lot of work that Nisheeth is doing is essentially trying to
exactly make these mathematically precise definitions
of a particular what fairness means,
to meet what is our notion or what will be our desired notion of fairness?
Again, we will get back to this in our discussion, but then, of
course, we have to realize that the fact that these systems work differently,
is also the source of the performance.
They are different to us,
that's why they can provide something that we don't have.
There is a little bit of distinction.
In particular, I think the big question here is,
how do we navigate this trade-off
between letting the systems extract the patterns the way they see fit,
which again might lead to also new discoveries,
discoveries we actually want to and discoveries to have versus our instinct naturally like
a responsibility to make sure we understand what
the systems are doing and that they don't go out of bounds.
The way I like to put it is that,
we have a tendency,
the way these things are phrased in the popular science that we think of ML as a hammer.
Have a problem, you just bring ML on this and you are done.
It's really not a hammer.
If I have to use an analogy,
I would call it a sharp knife.
Something that can work very well if you know what you're
doing but you can hurt yourself badly.
In particular, again, correlation extractor is what I call the double-edged sword of ML.
It gives its power but also the problems within particular,
realizing that you look at the hiring data and realize that well,
you can get idea that if you play Lacrosse and your first name is
Jared, then you are destined to be good employee.
All of these things exactly stem from
mistaking correlation for causation
and, of course, on top of the biases that our models have.
Data matters a lot, again,
this is at the core of the robust and safety problems,
but it also drives a lot of ML-related inequities.
It also leads to many other unintended consequences that I will not go into.
Let me conclude by saying that what I view as where we are hopefully trying to go,
is truly deployable MLs.
ML that we can deploy and we can feel good about.
Again, this is not something that machine
learning researchers or even computer scientists solve.
This is a much broader question.
Yes, there is a role for machine learning researchers and engineers, but they also need to
recognize that these are really complex and messy tasks,
and real-world data is really not what they can just nicely model.
There is more to it. They need to understand that role.
Then, there is a role for domain practitioners.
They really have to clarify how the data, the systems are
supposed to use was collected and also what are the actual correct objectives
that we should be after to?
Finally, and again, I don't know how interested Nisheeth will be going in that direction,
but I find it very interesting,
is you have to realize that there's a role for decision and policy-makers.
You need to acknowledge that there are trade-offs there,
that we should decide how we want to navigate them.
Again, this had the society because different trade-offs might play
differently for different stakeholders, and we need to make a decision.
I really talk too much about things that relate to my work.
If you want to learn more, you can see it here.
I just want to close it off at saying
that robustness and reliability is really important, and it's
an important question, but it's just a part of
the bigger question of this phenomenon that we are seeing right now.
That data-driven decision-making percolates just about every aspect of our lives.
At first, it was things like algorithmic trading that most of us didn't care about
but then slowly but surely it started bordering and touch on really scary things.
I think the two points that I want to highlight here is that first of all,
we do not understand what these consequences of
using data-driven decision-making in this context have.
We are only discovering it almost by just trying it out and seeing what happens.
Really not the best way to do it, but that's where we are.
Again, I want to emphasize because this is very important,
is that in all the things I talk about in my work, especially in the vision,
yes, it's difficult to get
reliable and robust systems and there are many fundamental reasons for that.
But at least we agree what robust and reliable systems mean like.
We have a gold standard of human vision and we
can agree if this is a correct behavior or not.
In many of the questions that we pursue in
this broader agenda and in particular the ones that Nisheeth touches on,
we don't even agree necessarily what the desired behavior is.
We can really disagree about what is fair,
what is not fair, and many other concepts that come out in the context of the systems.
That's something that we need to recognize upfront.
I really view it as a really important challenge
for us scientists, but also going beyond that.
In particular, the questions like how we as scientists can
engage with the real-world to provide some.
We should not be telling people what to do but at least we
should be able to make sure they understand what's the problem.
But anyway, I talked enough and I would like to just move to the discussion.
I have a few questions, but I'm happy to give it to Nisheeth based
on this talk, but I'm happy to also follow Priya's lead how we go next.
Thank you so much, Aleksander for
this wonderful defining of your vantage point and your point of view on these matters.
Before we go right into the question,
I have a couple of simple questions that come from a slightly different direction.
You know machine learning and AI have been considered
hugely promising, for example,
in my fields in astronomy and physics and other disciplines.
As a way for revealing, as you said,
these underlying correlations that may or may not have causation,
the challenge is that in physics at least, we have laws that structure our expectation,
so we know that certain quantities are conserved and so on, so forth.
I would like you both to also engage a little bit about
the intellectual domain and discovery space.
What these methods are doing for discovery space?
We're all enthusiastic, but are there things we need to be cautious about?
What are the things you would alert us scientists in other fields?
We're all really excited and want to use machine learning to do X, Y, and Z.
Then, I also realize that in the example that you showed us with ImageNet,
isn't there an issue of incompleteness of data?
Isn't that a fundamental inherent limit?
Not all attributes of dogliness are known, right?
Hypothetically, would you both,
I mean I'd like to hear both of your responses to this.
If hypothetically we were able to define the entire space of attributes,
complex multi-dimensional space of all the attributes that define dogliness,
then would the recognition,
in your opinion, would that be perfect?
Would that be enough?
How important is the incompleteness other than the planting and biases the examples?
Let me start by taking a stab at both of your questions, Priya.
For the first question,
I think this is very important to take into account the invariances in the data domain.
There is a branch of machine learning which is beginning to do that.
Even the examples that Aleksander was showing,
images, they have invariances.
In particular, you can rotate an image and
your opinion about the image should not change.
As far as I remember,
Aleksander, correct me if I'm wrong.
I mean, the original machine learning systems are not even robust to
these kinds of the simple rotations. Am I right?
Yes. It's all right.
I think the issue there was that if we know symmetries of the data,
we have to then design algorithms that take into account those symmetries.
This then leads to problems on manifolds because the moment you have symmetries,
the mathematics gets complex.
The traditional thing that
Aleksander was describing is a straightforward Euclidean space.
You're doing optimization in Euclidean space.
On manifolds, optimization gets complicated
because you only know your tangent space at this point.
You don't necessarily know how you're going to take
long steps and the computational cost starts increasing.
But there is something called Geometric Deep Learning, which is coming up.
To your second question,
I can give a more mathematical answer to that.
I mean, so the question of what does dogliness mean
is I'm not sure one can ever define that.
But in his classic,
beautiful theory on PAC learnability,
Leslie Valiant who is a Turing Award winner and one of the founders of learning theory,
he did introduce the notion of a distribution from these data accounts.
The setting of learning theory is the following,
that you have some unknown distribution and you're given independent samples from
that distribution and so you should only
be tested against samples from that distribution.
The assumption, and Aleksander will talk much more about it,
the assumption in many of these algorithms is that,
which is wrong as you point out,
it's not necessarily incompleteness.
It's like we don't know what dogliness is,
what this distribution is and we certainly don't.
What is the ideal?
We certainly don't believe that we have IID, the independent samples from
the space of dogliness and I think Aleksander made this point by these fishes,
which is very important.
I mean, in this literature,
there is a theory which says that if you are given samples from the true distribution,
then you can quantify
the quality of the algorithm with respect to samples from the same distribution.
Yeah, I guess that's all I have to say.
I was curious because the reason I asked with dogliness is because, obviously,
the more real-world complex issue is,
what is the ideal candidate?
When we are making candidate selections and so on.
These things also keep changing with time.
I mean, as a society, and I'll move this discussion a little bit to what
Aleksander was saying towards the end of his talk,
that as a society,
we might have grown up with two genders,
male and female, but today, even that's not true.
It's very dynamically changing.
I mean, forget fairness,
I mean fairness with respect to what?
We don't even know what that 'what' is.
We can define fairness once we know what to define fairness with respect to.
If the notion of dog and cat is evolving over time,
then how can we think about designing
algorithms which are shared with respect to dogs and cats?
I think that's even a more fundamental issue,
at least when it comes to things like bias.
Now, probably, this is not happening in the physical world,
where the equations that govern black holes are changing.
At least the assumption is,
that the laws of physics are not mutating over time.
There are some differences between these areas.
Maybe one extreme is really the physical world,
where things are very nice,
well-defined, or at least you have some idea of the model.
I would add that even if you go
back to the history of physics and how Kepler discovered his laws,
I mean, I'm not an expert on all this stuff,
but looking at data, he discovered new laws.
It is entirely possible that by looking at data,
you can revise the laws of physics.
I'm sure you're working on things like that.
It is true that many of the laws were actually empirically discovered.
That is definitely true.
When the data was not as complex either,
and now the data is much more complex.
But Aleksander, I might invite you to
ask Nisheeth any specific questions that you had in mind.
Sure, let me just complement to what Nisheeth said.
I just zoom out a little bit.
I think if you think about how we create knowledge around the world, they're like two.
Again, at the very high level, two ways of doing it.
One of them is we postulate models like that's actually much of physics.
There is a law of physics,
and we say this is how the universe works.
Based on that, we derive the experiments.
We have predictions of how things should work.
Then there's data-driven thing,
when we exactly look at the observations,
and we try to crystallize from this.
What symmetry is in, what patterns we see.
So clearly, machine learning is in the second count,
and that's why I can imagine and I can
actually share with you some excitement about doing that.
There's a lot of, I would say,
practical challenges there which already Nisheeth mentioned to.
The sample complexity of learning something reliable from data is quite enormous.
The way this is called the machine learning is a prior.
You had these laws of universe, you need to have a prior.
You posted from symmetries.
Now, even to get this in work,
you needed to have convolutional neural networks,
so you had to postulate this spatial invariance as a way
to really reduce the space of concepts that the modal explored.
Similar things need to happen in this context of different sciences,
and yes, geometric deep learning is trying to provide a framework for that.
This is one approach of understanding the world, building knowledge about the world.
But on the other end, of course, the answer is no.
They are really very complementary.
Like in some ways, I don't think that
ever you will learn what dog is just purely from data.
But I could imagine that
there is certain notion of something data-driven,
the texture of the fur, you can learn maybe from data.
But then there are certain concepts that a dog has four legs actually.
My concept of a dog is changing as well.
Other aspects that might be encoding to modeling.
Again, there is a very interesting question of imaging.
Aleksander, it's not so much if one method is better than the other.
The question is in the scientific domain,
it is which is more reliable in terms of explanatory power and predictive power?
Okay. That's great.
The question is what reliable means.
Like clearly, what we are striving to is to have beautiful equations.
That's what physics excel is like beautiful equations that explain everything.
And predict.
And predict, of course. You can have a beautiful algorithm that doesn't predict anything,
then you don't care.
But of course, we know that sometimes when we really want
to fit real-world like we looked at [inaudible] model.
Things become a bit messy saying,
here we have these constants and so on.
It's amazing. It predicts so much.
But yes, the reliability here is,
I think in the end, the way we as humans,
I don't think we can communicate via data to each other what things.
I think in the end, we are biased towards models and priors
because that's the only thing that is compact enough for us to do.
In some ways, again, I don't want to go to philosophical,
but to me, the role of machine learning is to be a bit of opposite to us.
I think one big power of ML is just being really able to understand,
infer simple rules from a lot of data.
Just being able to cognitively just process the data,
even if not very deep way, something complementary.
Like I think we can go very deep,
but on a very small volume of data.
ML can do a bit opposite in some ways,
that's why I never really like when people say about supplanting humans with ML.
I think it's really should be always about complementing humans from ML.
Since our notion of reliability is really we like to have a
concise model that predicts, the data-driven stuff
always will be less reliable.
Essentially, we would like to use it to then formulate
the laws that we actually are comfortable with.
Thank you.
Okay. Let me ask a few questions to Nisheeth based on your talk.
Essentially in the talk, you already articulated,
there is a little bit, there are two components of
this data-driven decision-making system.
It's like one of them is data,
like what are the kinds of biases in data to be learned.
But the other is the objective.
In the end, you are learning the data,
essentially the model is performing optimization to optimize something.
As we know by now, both aspects matter,
so what is your thinking about the relative importance of these?
And if you think about improving the way these systems work moving forward,
which might be easier to improve?
What is the hope here in terms of improvement?
In terms of impact, the objective that we
optimize in many of these algorithms play a much bigger role, in my opinion.
Because the moment you write down an objective,
so let's take an example of college admissions,
and college admissions is something that probably everybody has personal experience with.
When we talk about something like college admissions,
we historically have been using things like SAT scores,
to what extent do they play
a role in the decision, that's been changing and that's debatable.
But let's pretend for a moment that there are colleges
which will just look at your SAT score and decide whether you get in or not.
Now, the real question here is,
is what the college looking for in a student for their university,
what is the college looking for at the university,
and why are we using SAT score and whether it is the right thing to do?
Now, we're realizing that it is not the right thing to do
because it measures something else compared to what we are trying to measure.
The moment we create a metric,
a metric in this setting is a value judgment, that we value this.
The moment we create a value system by writing down an objective function,
certain segments of society will figure out how to be
good in that value system as opposed to what the original objective of the university is.
To answer your question in short,
I think this is really important.
I cannot emphasize it more.
At universities, we talk about diversity,
and every university is right now on a path to increase diversity.
I would go ahead and say here that
most universities don't have any idea what they are doing.
This brings back to your point, the second last point you made,
we don't know what the implications of our policy decisions on increasing diversity is.
Because in the end, you will implement these diversity decisions based on some objectives.
Maybe we will have a dean of diversity who is black, and what does being black mean?
Is it okay if somebody who is black but they lived in a
completely privileged life all throughout their life?
I'm not sure to what extent these discussions are even happening,
and so the objective function as to how to
select a candidate for a position is misaligned as you called it.
I think that data component is secondary.
Once there is an agreement that this is what we want to optimize,
that's where then comes the issue of,
do we know everything about the data that we need to know?
This question is not specific to bias.
This is in your work, this is in Priya's work.
This happens in every discipline where data-driven discovery is happening.
Do we know everything about the data that we need to know?
What are these systems in which we can write down the assumptions on data?
For example, I talked a little bit about correlations between data,
so I do not know what the correlations might be.
Maybe I just use an adversarial model saying
that because I do not know what the correlation is that we quantified by saying that
the adversary can introduce arbitrary correlations in data,
and I have a measure of how many data points the adversary can touch.
Based on that, I will now design an algorithm,
based on this knowledge, this is meta knowledge.
I think we are moving in this direction.
We are not moving so much in the direction
of trying to understand what are the objectives,
and I think that cannot be something that would be done by
technical or mathematical people.
This is where the domain expertise has to come in.
Even inside a domain,
we have to have discussions which take into account various sectors in society.
For example, let me give you a controversial quote here,
the Nobel Prizes got announced recently.
I'd like to make the discussion more interesting, I guess.
The Nobel Prizes got announced recently,
and the Chair of the Nobel Prize Committee, Priya, correct me if I'm wrong,
comes out and says that, we are not,
I mean they're criticized for not having other than a single
woman being awarded and they come out and make some, in my opinion,
outrageous statements without any understanding of what the system is.
Does the system evaluate women and men in the same manner?
What is the system? Who decides?
If you are evaluating scientific content,
please do not talk like this is a godly evaluation process.
These are 100 percent human evaluation processes.
This has 100 percent human biases,
and we all should acknowledge that to say the least,
and certain groups get evaluated lower in this,
not because their work is any worse.
It's just because how the evaluation systems are set up in society.
When we evaluate, we should understand what we are evaluating,
and the data that is coming to us,
would the data for one group be biased compared to the other?
Right from the biggest achievements that we celebrate to
the smallest things in places like Africa,
we see a huge disparity in just our understanding of data.
COVID-19 has shown what significant disparity is in data.
I mean, it's a long answer to your question,
but I think the higher-order thing is objective,
and then the lower order,
which I think is currently tractable and at least we're asking the right questions,
and you and I are both working in this for
different objectives like reliability, responsibility, and bias.
I think the ultimate goal is trying to understand what we can use about the data.
But isn't one fundamental issue that we may not all agree even on the metrics?
This is what I refer to as participatory design of metrics.
In the end, we have to agree,
so we have to identify which group it affects,
and then we have to bring them onto the table and have a discussion.
But ultimately, we can go closer and closer to the true thing,
but we will never reach the true goal.
But for the ML systems to work,
do you think we need to become a society that has shared values first?
Is that a prerequisite?
Aleksander, I will let you take this.
This is actually going to my next question in some way, but before that,
I liked the point you made, Nisheeth.
Just one more thing is exactly like that,
there is an interesting paper that shows that even if you try
to make a fairness intervention in context of consumer lending.
You want to make sure that certain groups which are,
for systemic reasons, under-privileged,
that they actually do affirmative action to improve their lending to them,
which if you look at this, we did something good in the world.
Again, remember, we are not only predicting things,
we're are making decisions, and since we have consequences,
it turns out if you look at the long-term dynamics that comes out of that.
Some of these people actually, it's really hard for them to pay back the loans.
Again, there are some systemic reasons behind that,
why they don't have enough wealth,
but this is reality.
You are letting these people get a loan.
They actually are more likely to not pay it
back and that hurts their credit score even more.
In the end, by having intervention that was supposed to do the right thing,
you actually hurt them even more as a population moving forward and even individuals.
This is something that both Nisheeth lament.
There's not enough recognition of importance of the objectives.
In the end, this is about how I make my accuracy better,
not even thinking of accuracy on what and what does it represent?
The moment you start peeling under this,
you realize that there is a lot of problems,
a lot of assumptions here.
Now, going into my next question because exactly,
I think what I'm learning,
my work causes me to think a lot and your questions and discussions sync.
There's little bit of double standards here.
Like in some ways we say, "This machine learning system,
it's unfair, it's doing this,
doing that, and what is the exact objective that it's using?"
On the other hand, we have human decision-making.
First of all, much of what the machine learning does
is to just uncover the biases and inequities of human decision-making,
just makes it apparent,
maybe that's the uncomfortable truth here that we don't want to acknowledge.
The other thing is saying, the admissions decisions
are made by human-based committee which in the past
talked about character and other things and the feat,
and there is no one,
in some ways, we seemed to be okay with that and now we are saying,
this machine learning things,
they are so bad, we should not be using them.
I think that a little bit of reckoning here,
and I think that's what Priya actually talked about and saying that,
yes, and I agree with Nisheeth but we should have an honest conversation about objectives,
in particular, if we talk about Nobel Prizes,
let's go a little bit there.
Why did we assume that some committee of people in Sweden decide?
Why are we even giving away the Nobel Prizes?
This is still arbitrary.
There could be some value in this,
but the point is it seems to be a proxy for like
if you've got a Nobel Prize, you are a God of science.
If you didn't, you didn't.
There's marketing associated to it.
Yes, the point is that,
I'm not saying every award has a problem, which is fine.
As long as you have an honest conversation that
this is what these things are
and we should have an honest like it's a recognition of that.
I feel compelled to point out,
one of the things that this spokesperson was completely,
I think he revealed his ignorance in so many ways.
I mean, the basic point is that there is
a fundamental difference in the number of women who do get nominated in the first place,
let alone whether they are considered or not and eventually get the prize.
To not even understand and acknowledge that that is a systemic bottleneck,
it was quite depressing and irritating.
Yeah. But I think, Aleksander, you're right.
This is how I think about this.
I realized that this is why this area got so much importance because
in the end, it definitely proved that humans are biased.
Because it's not like we're receiving these algorithms
from other civilizations, we are constructing these.
We are collecting the data.
Whatever is the reason,
it's a definitive proof that we are biased.
I think that's why things like Kathy O'Neill's book that came out,
it caught media attention.
I think it is giving us insight.
It's providing a lens to our own society, to our own self.
It is. But if you look at the coverage of this, it is not
that humans are biased, it's algorithmic bias.
We are really protecting ourselves from
letting this implication sink in. This is interesting.
Again, even if you think about people who talk about these things,
even they don't make this point strongly enough because
maybe it should be uncomfortable truth and so on.
Again, I agree. This is actually definitive proof.
I would say that while I was thinking about this talk, I realized this.
I mean, I would be a little bit gentler because it is an obvious thing in retrospect,
but it took me also a few years to just have this realization that this is.
But maybe there are people.
Certainly, a very valid point
now that you mentioned and that people say algorithms are biased.
They don't say that human-designed algorithms are biased.
As if algorithms are being shipped to us from MIT, which is another planet.
Only good things come from MIT.
It's almost like a rock shock test.
It's like saying, you are designing an algorithm and saying,
what should be the objective?
Then you run it through the data.
Only then you realize, that's not what I meant or maybe that's what I meant all the time,
but now it's actually laid bare to us.
This is great. That's a very important realization.
It hits you a bit hard once you make it because you realize, that's it.
Anyway, let's not go too much into that.
But let's try to see a little bit of maybe positive spin to all of this.
Again, clearly using blindly data-driven decision-making is really bad idea.
I think hopefully we all got that message well.
Not all got that message,
but hopefully, we are getting this message.
But now let's think about like,
what do we think is the correct or a bit more beneficial and inclusive?
I'm talking about shared prosperity beneficial way of using such systems.
What are the places where we should be using them?
How should we be using them? Do you have any suggestions here, Nisheeth?
It takes me back to the previous point, for us,
we need to as a society first have some shared values.
We need to first agree on what are the values.
There are contexts in which you can imagine that there are shared values.
Let's say if you're an organization, a university,
then in such small university,
as you can imagine, that people have some shared values,
and there I think we have to work together to figure
out the right objectives that we are optimizing,
making sure that we know everything about the data,
and that we can know and then design policies or
algorithms based on such inclusive and parallel thinking.
I'm talking more in general terms of algorithms in which I include policies,
and not just machine learning,
just to be very clear in this context.
I should mention that the machine learning Aleksander does
is the state of the art and he's using some really deep architectures to learn things,
and the world of fairness and bias
has not reached that point that it can start grappling with objects like this.
The reason is actually fairly simple on this point because it's mathematical.
Let me just explain.
I think this is important for some people,
Aleksander would probably explain it better, but let me just try.
When we talk about objective functions,
there is some assumption that when we will now solve this optimization problem,
there is this one point that we're trying to reach.
But there is no such thing in many of these models that Aleksander studies.
They have very, very complex landscapes.
They have many, many local optima.
What shall I do as a person who cares about fairness?
Different points on this landscape,
there may be completely different properties related to fairness.
From an accuracy of performance point of view,
you can select maybe one.
The thing works in some way because all of these local optimal points are good points.
But from the point of view of fairness,
it's not at all clear how to even do that. What do you think?
Nisheeth, just to chime in quickly,
but these multiple optima, maxima or whatever in that landscape,
don't they represent basically value trade-offs?
You are trading something, there is no one clear-cut solution,
but that the solution space represents,
in the case of these more social domain problems like trade-offs.
But I think what we're talking about are some really, at least,
I view them as very ugly landscapes, where it's not I think
what we're imagining that there's multiple optimum solution,
they are related by some symmetry,
and so there's some trade-off.
I don't think anybody understands this. I mean, Aleksander.
Complicated.
Definitely, no one understands it.
Again, I think I liked the point you made earlier that,
you made in the context of data,
we don't even know what we want to accomplish.
Figuring out how to make this model do what you want to accomplish,
that's almost a secondary concern,
even though that's not being nontrivial.
Again, there's just so much not thinking about what we're even trying to do.
We have problems. We have been enforcing the behavior we want.
But I wouldn't say this is the root of the product.
This is the most important challenge right now,
even though of course, we should figure out.
This is mainly what you are working in the context of fairness.
That's something that also I do in the context of reliability saying,
maybe even like what robust means,
it may be hard to define.
But however, they provide you with tools that if you think you know what it is,
I can help you to make your model satisfy what you are looking for.
But we need to recognize that this is a challenge,
but it's secondary to me in terms of what the really important question is.
There's a very interesting audience question that I
would like to now pull up and articulate.
It's from Ferdous, who was one of our usual gang attendees.
He's asking, can you comment on the implications of
AI/ML as applied in the area of security intelligence,
facial recognition, surveillance, and others?
Aleksander, go first.
Sorry, because I needed to tell someone that because we're going
a bit overtime. Could you repeat? I'm sorry.
It's AI/ML applied in the area of security and intelligence.
The facial recognition, surveillance, and so on.
Yes. I think this is scary.
To be honest, when I work on my stuff,
there are some moments in the night where you are thinking,
"What are we enabling?"
Even though, of course, the uses we are using our tools for
I would say are I feel pretty confident and more about them.
There are clearly all the ways in which these things can be misused.
Going back to our discussion earlier is,
I think what we don't really appreciate is the ability of
the vastness of data that essentially whose analysis machine learning can automate.
I don't think we even understand machine learning in particular or facial recognition.
We don't even think about,
what is the level of what is enabled by doing that?
To be honest, I don't know that either.
If you wanted to see,
of course, there's facial recognition.
If we look at China and other countries,
then there are some challenges there.
Think about social media, for instance.
If you think about the level of surveillance that's happening there,
where not only what you like or not like,
or what you write is taken care of, they look at your cursor.
What do you even scroll over?
Where your cursor is? How long does it change? All of this is ingested.
It's just so easy to pull all these data,
shove into the systems.
Honestly, we no longer understand what you were extracting or not,
but the system just works on that.
To me, again, all the security aspects are very important.
This is another can of worms.
Not only it's about can someone compromise a system?
But the question is, people think about also in terms of offensive capabilities.
Can I automate my tools using ML,
making them media-driven, essentially remove the slow human from the loop?
This is scary and there are
some case scenarios that can emerge from these dynamics.
Preview of this was the stock market and
when you have automated trading and there was a flash crash.
I think that's just an example.
Again, everyone during that game wanted to get the right thing.
They just wanted to get efficiency.
They wanted to get this extra tick.
This is such a level of the social scale of data and interactions that we don't see.
But, again, let's not even talk about that.
Think about social media and about what emerges from, again, simple,
and I will even say simplistic objectives,
and then just shoving in all this data into it.
Just because it's so easy.
This worries me a lot. I think that's why we should talk about privacy more.
Not only because, again, privacy is, at least to me,
a fundamental right but also about this might be a way to curb
a little bit the unintended consequences of use of our data for optimizing everything.
Nisheeth, did you want to weigh in or?
I think Aleksander covered pretty much all that I would have said.
I think this technology is not ready.
I'll just add one thing to it.
Even though you might develop a piece of algorithm in a very controlled environment,
to give an analogy to cars or any other thing that people have more familiarity with.
Car production was systematized.
There were protocols that you have to follow and so on.
It doesn't work like that with algorithms.
You can design an algorithm in a very safe environment with lots of guarantees,
but now somebody takes that algorithm.
Tinkering a car is not so easy.
Common people cannot. Here you can open
the Python code and just start changing the rates somewhere.
Or just feed it on a few more examples.
In the end, the model that you train,
it can be used as starting point for something else.
There are some very complex things like data poisoning and this and that.
It's just a jungle out there.
Even if you develop a piece of algorithm in a very precise and licensed context,
when we give it to somebody to use,
we basically lock it out somehow,
so they can't change any aspect of it.
I think that's what I would say.
The technology is not ready for any of these tasks.
The biases are already in there.
The biases with respect to facial recognition and so on are already in there.
We need to rethink how we want to design this technology completely,
both from a reliability point of view and from a fairness point of view.
Let's close with one final question from our audience,
which is related to the topics you both touched upon right now.
This is also from Jenny, who's one of our regulars.
How far does the sample size of data
also play a role in the development of fair algorithms?
Some questions can only be based on the law of
small numbers instead of in the limit of large numbers.
How to take sparse correlated samples into account?
This is a great question.
We have some works which try to take into account correlations,
whether they're stochastic or adversarial,
and then work out the sample complexity bounds for learning classifiers.
Classification is one of the basic machine learning tasks.
There's no answer for this in general.
It can only be with respect to a particular problem.
The problem is classification.
We are working towards it,
and there are certain precise mathematical solutions to these problems.
I'm not sure that I can explain more without going into mathematical details.
Yes. I just want to say,
I know probably it wasn't meant by the question,
but we need to be careful with the mantra of more data will solve problems because,
again, more data might have just reinforced the same bias.
We might be thinking we're making progress where we aren't.
There's a lot of question about exactly
data is independent or is in some ways provides different perspective.
It actually would be fine if these perspectives are biased,
as long as they are biased in different ways.
Actually, we even have a word that tries to exactly use
that perspective of I have automated this biased in some way,
but these are different biases.
You can play them against each other to realize what is the less biased perspective.
But yes, this is a bit of a problem in the community was that people just said,
"I train it on such a big dataset,
so it has to be good because,
again, accuracy goes up."
In particular, GPT-3 is trained on a lot of texts.
Again, it's very impressive.
Actually, I would bet that there are a lot of
biases in it that we probably wouldn't like to have.
Data is definitely needed,
but it's definitely not sufficient to solve this problem.
Great. I think much as I would have loved us to keep talking,
because it's absolutely fascinating,
and learned a lot,
and our audience is really thrilled to have this opportunity,
I think we need to call it to a close.
I would like to thank both of you,
Aleksander and Nisheeth,
for participating in this exciting series,
trying to understand the role of data, computation,
machine learning in what we can infer about the world and how we infer about the world.
Thank you everyone for attending and I look
forward to seeing you at the next talk in this series,
which will be led by Kyle Cranmer,
who is a physicist at NYU who works on machine learning
applied to particle physics experimental data.
I also want to take this opportunity to say happy Thanksgiving break
to all of you who hopefully can catch up a few restful days with your families.
Thank you, everyone,
and good evening. Bye.